what about when you were a little kid
and the cuban missile crisis was going
on did that did that have any heat on
the family or no
no no that's what i wanted to talk to
you guys about today because
you guys are [ __ ] intelligent as [ __ ]
i want you to break it down for me
let's do it let's do it
so i want you [ __ ] to break and
before
we move any further i want to give a
shout out to my nephew luke gallo
he's the one that turned me on to you
guys nice the one
he talked me into [ __ ] going on your
guy's show
he said you guys are great you're
fascinating so here i am because of my
nephew
so you guys thank you fans out there
that [ __ ] reached out to me and said
those are two solid [ __ ] up
there in brooklyn so
and i promise you next time next time i
come up but this week there's no school
in jersey
yeah because of the [ __ ] conference
so i had to just throw my wife out
i had to tell her you got to go yeah
because the sun is out
my wife's like from tennessee she's like
well it's windy out who gives a
frenchman's [ __ ] you're american indian
you people grew up in the [ __ ] wind
get the [ __ ] out there's no coffee
there's no
oh yeah my wife's american indian and uh
irish
and i'm cute but this is a bad
combination here
so when i'm trying to do a podcast and i
want to go off i can't hack my daughter
upstairs
no yeah my wife for some reason i come
home today from the gym
and i'm like what's going on here she's
like well it's windy out you're [ __ ]
american indian you guys grew up on the
[ __ ] wing
you know i can't even sneak up on an
indian and you're worried about the wind
get out there
yeah beg for snow whatever the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] into
now yeah i got a little hack free kid i
got a cuban american indian kid are you
[ __ ] nuts
we all i gotta hit in the pads this
morning i'm a [ __ ] savage
you're amazing dude yeah yeah you look
good well you gotta have we all got well
i got my my daughter's half puerto rican
yeah and then yanis yannis is uh
a half greek half italian which to the
greeks if it's not greek it's a half
breed
yeah no it's three quarters and you're
irish chris
um i yeah irish italian and german so
just a classic [ __ ] brooklyn mutt
and then the puerto rican you
[ __ ] love those spanish women
yeah i couldn't get enough of it yeah
you can't yeah
i know [ __ ] love your spanish
me i like those dirty irish chicks yeah
well i'm a catholic dude
i went by [ __ ] saint michael's i did
the whole thing
getting an irish chick with a little
dirt on her heels
you know what i'm saying [ __ ] love it
give me an irish chick with red hair
and [ __ ] freckles on the titties i
love the world i love irish chicks
yeah irish chicks always got a little
dirt on their knees or they're oh yeah
yeah a little dirty yeah and they and
they tolerate me because their dads are
[ __ ] crazy
yeah so my best friends are irish chicks
because they're used to their dads being
nuts so
yeah that's my favorite i if i look back
well i'm married i can't say this but
yeah whatever i say for you i just feel
like it's worth it
to be catholic for how freaky it makes
you people
right like you catholics are freaky
people because you grow up thinking it's
bad
and then so when you get into the game
it's all nasty [ __ ] yeah and i
appreciate that yeah
it sucks it sucks like i really bought
the catholicism thing guys like i really
was all in
i was a young cuban guy but i gotta tell
you i still remember sucking
my first set of thirties behind the
church and thinking i was gonna die in
the winter
yeah i thought you know and i
i built like a little [ __ ] glue the
next day like i wanted to
i wanted that you know i was a young kid
and some girl gave me a little funnel
tits but the first time i sucked titties
it was behind a church for a week i
walked around thinking god was gonna
kill me
like yeah that's how catholic i was i
think the first time i fingerbanged the
chick too was buying a church
you did all your nasty activities in the
church yeah yeah
first time i got jerked off was in a
rock in the woods by a catholic girl
from catholic school
saviors yeah because you're not because
yeah that's
especially what i thought she was she
was doing school yeah they're ready to
suck dick they're ready to go
it was she was [ __ ] crazy she was
doing hail mary's the whole time she was
doing it
yeah it was she was she was asking for
forgiveness while she was doing it
and that turned me on a little bit yeah
yeah i [ __ ] crazy
same thing with me dude i would never
you know being catholic i'm saying joey
catholic my whole life
i would never jerk off on good friday
because that's the day jesus died you
got to have [ __ ] penance
i would never i would never allow myself
to jerk off on fridays because that's no
good
um i would jerk off on easter sunday
because you were excited that jesus rose
from the dead and was coming back
so that celebration you [ __ ] jerk off
you're so happy and i i never jerk off
on 9 11 because i'm a catholic patriot
yeah you can't do that yeah
what made you guys lose your interest in
the catholic church when
how old were you when you like i think
the pre the priest [ __ ] kids had
something to do with it for me
yeah that whole thing but you are you
already over 18.
i was over 18 but just a couple of those
news stories i was like you know what i
think there's some
fishy stuff happening in the basement of
where i played cyo basketball
i still and joey and i still am catholic
i got catholic tattoos all over my body
i still consider myself a soldier in the
army of jesus
but i don't go to church at all anymore
but my daughter but my you know my
daughter goes to catholic school
she's baptized you know my mother's very
very irish catholic [ __ ] red hair
you know very so so i still consider
myself catholic but not practicing
as much anymore but really i didn't
really start to have negative feelings
toward the catholic church until
until uh i met giannis because make no
mistake giannis is a negative nancy
pelosi
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild
[Music]